it's okay the bank of England have taken
emergency action today to stem the
crisis in the markets you've called for
a parliament recall the IMF have asked
the government to evaluate tax cuts so
Charlie being a former deputy governor
of the bank of England has warned the
government might be left with little
option but to cut public spending so
significantly it could result in the end
of the NHS how worried are you it's a
really very serious situation for the
bank of England to have to take that
action today on the back of the IMF
statement on the back of what the bank
of England said on Monday and this is a
self-inflicted wound the government has
lost control of the economy and that's
not some International event that wasn't
expected this is their deliberate
decision and why did they do it for tax
cuts for the very rich and now there's a
lot lots of loss of confidence in what
they've done and so you said they should
reverse the budget point one they need
to reverse the budget before any more
done should resign and if they just on
the reversing the budget if they recall
Parliament which is what they should do
they can't just walk past this now
pretend it's not happening recall
Parliament reverse the budget if they do
that we will act in the National
interest and we will support that to
ensure that no further damage is
chancellor should resign well look as
for the individuals involved and at the
moment that's secondary the primary
action that's needed is this recall of
parliament I mean I honestly don't think
that for people who are looking at their
mortgages and their bills their price is
going through they're now worried about
their pensions if the government tries
to just walk past this and ignore it
you're making a huge but the chance it
does matter because if you think they
should reverse the budget and the
markets don't think they've got uh
confidence in the chances then he should
resign well look I mean there's the
chance why won't you just say that I
need a prime minister it's not just the
chancellor the Prime Minister and the
chance we're working together uh in this
so as they both resign well look the
first thing they need to do is recall
Parliament and reverse this budget and I
wanted to see them do that immediately
before any more damages done and if they
do the labor party so okay this isn't
political Point scoring literally if you
think that the budget needs to be
reserved verse because the markets have
lost confidence in it then the chances
should resign well look I think
people look at their bills and worrying
today not interested in who I'm calling
for to resign they want to know is the
goal well I'm interested is the
government going to recall Parliament
and reverse the cause of this decline
that they've lost control of you okay so
you don't want to call on Liz Trussell
well it's secondary for the moment for
me
you called on Boris Johnson to resign
for his uh Behavior around partygate but
you won't call on the current prime
minister to resign for the chaos she's
causing to the market it's not that I
don't think it's important whether they
resign or not but what I think is most
important is that they recall Parliament
and reverse that budget because you can
see what's happening with the market
it's either actually the bank of England
have taken and this translate these are
not just graphs on a page that we look
at in some abstract for millions of
people that impacts their mortgages
their prices now their pensions and they
will be sick uh to make Here For
Heaven's Sake the first thing that needs
to happen is to reverse the budget so we
can deal with this decline so you do
think it's important to just to pick up
on that and you do think they should
consider their positions well look it's
not my primary concern at the moment my
primary concern is that the government
doesn't try to walk past the problem of
their own creation okay this this is
this is a you know this is a loss of
control of the economy made in Downing
Street and never again can the
conservative party claim to be the party
and I want to respond to you as the
Prime Minister potentially fiscal
responsibility and ceremony but final
question is list trust a dangerous prime
minister well look I don't think it's
helpful for me to start branding Liz
trust in that way she's clearly lost
control of the economy and she needs to
come to Parliament straight away and
reverse that budget that's the
responsible thing to do
do you think she's dangerous to the
economy well they've lost control of the
economy I'm not that's do you think
that's a dangerous course it's a danger
they took a huge risk they're like you
know two gamblers in a casino you know
chasing a losing run but they're not
gambling their money they're gambling
our money they're gambling the money of
people watching this program and that's
what's so wrong about this and what for
to give tax breaks it's quite something
when I talk to conservative MPS that say
we think the Chance is going to have to
go because the economic turmoil and then
I asked the labor leader what he thinks
and he would like to be the Prime
Minister and they're more bold in what
they think in the prognosis than you I
mean it's just an observation but if
you're asking I don't see why it's a
problem for you to answer that question
Beth if you're asking me which is more
important I don't know the resignation
of the chancellor or recalling
Parliament to reverse the budget I'd say
recalling Parliament reversing the
budget but you think he should consider
his position well if it were you they
took took well if it were us we'd never
gone down this road in the first place
the idea of unfunded tax cuts for those
at the very top inflicting price
increases on working people and anxiety
about mortgages and pensions is
something that we would never
contemplate as labor government okay let
me let me go on then to the economy if
labor of the party of sound money to
restore Market confidence you're going
to need either fairly steep tax Rises or
spending cuts do you accept that
principle well what we've said is that
we'll have very clear fiscal rules which
is we will pay for day-to-day spend we
will only borrow to invest and we want
the debt to reduce as a share of our GDP
so they're the rules that we will
operate to obviously I don't know the
state of the economy when we inherited
that principle though well what I want
to do is to grow the economy and that's
why I set out such a clear plan
yesterday so let's just drill down a
little bit it into what you have said
about that emergency yeah about all that
non-budget budget that you now think
should be reversed you're actually
keeping 20 billion pounds of those tax
cuts in the ni decision uh you are also
reversing two billion of them but then
you're spending that immediately that's
half of the the tax cuts you are keeping
how on Earth is that economically
responsible I literally how can you do
that right and claim that you are the
party of sound money while you say that
the conservatives are not a number of
answers to that firstly we've made it
very clear we would reverse the tax
break for those earning hundreds of
thousands of pounds yeah and then you've
spent in it secondly we're very very
clear we would cancel the cut to
corporation tax which amounts to up to
18.
thirdly we've said we'd have a windfall
tax on oil and gas companies made excess
profits that's tens of billions a pound
the government won't touch fourthly
we've said that we would change the Nom
Dom status which is about three billion
pounds on top of all of that I listened
very carefully to what was said by the
government on Friday in relation to the
National Insurance uh cut and they were
very clear that the money going to the
NHS would still be there so that's the
situation that we would inherit but you
do you can see from a viewer's point of
view this guy tells me he's sound money
but he keeps half of the tax cuts that
he says are are irresponsible you you
can see why people think should I trust
labor on the economy no you don't you
think that's okay opposite every single
spending commitment we've made we've
explained where the money's going to
come from complete opposite of the
government and so every single thing and
that will be the situation going into
the election we don't know obviously
what the economy will be like but we
have we've already instilled the
discipline of making sure I said to my
shadow cabinet if we're making an
announcement that costs money then I
need to see the funding and we've set
that out very very good I'll continue
today I'm running out of time and I
really want to ask you this income tax
cuts funded by wealth taxes is that the
direction of travel we had a long
conversation about wealth taxes over a
year ago you really did not want to say
I think we will need wealth taxes are
you now prepared to say that the economy
will need fixing if you are prime
minister you have to look again at
wealth taxes wealth tax the term wealth
tax means different things to different
people but let me be clear
um
so for example in relation to people who
earn their income from stocks and shares
and dividends then yes we are looking at
what is a fair taxation approach in
relation to that we'll set it out you
know I think there's a lot of thought
that if you earn your income through
wages you paid a certain rate but if you
earn it through stocks and shares and
dividend you've had a different rate
that is something we need to look so
that's a broad shift isn't it because at
the moment the conservatives seem to be
taxing income yes or they were into
these big taxes they're taxing income
and they're impacting working people the
hardest just on the Prime Minister she's
on 164 000 so she benefits from that top
rate of tax being cut do you think she
should give that money to charity
whatever profit she makes from it well
maybe she should
um what she should do which is more
important than that is to stop
inflicting this damage on working people
because and that's the direct action of
her government so what she does
personally is up to her frankly what
she's inflicting on the rest of the
country is what she needs to take
responsibility for I'm completely out of
time indulge me one more question on
that stage yesterday you were vote Tony
Blair in some of your language
the center ground the party of
aspiration the party of business but I
wonder whether when you first took this
job you thought you might be more like
Neil kinnick that you might be the
leader of the labor party he's got got
the party ready to get into power but it
would take another cycle and you weren't
going to be the guy is that fair do you
think you've gone from Clinic to Blair
no I never thought for a moment that it
was impossible to get the labor party
from where it landed in 2019 back into
government plenty of people when I
became leader labor party said good luck
here and then behind their breath said
but you'll never do it in one five-year
stretch here we are two and a half years
into my leadership
and a hope of a labor government has
turned into a belief of the labor
government we've done a huge amount
we've done change in the labor party
that took years last time we're in a
situation like this having changed the
labor party what I did yesterday and
what I will do here on is show what
change we can make for the country
so you're going to be our next prime
minister yes thank you very much